At one point, I realized that I was teaching
the course in a way that was sort of timeless.
And it's really about, I really wanted to
think about it much more in a way that was
set in context - of today and the history
of education in the past.
And I wanted to do that in a way that felt
like, again I was embodying the constructivist
principles that I really think are important
to learning.
And so the first thing I brought in was Current
Events.
I wanted students to bring in, to understand
what's going on in the world of education
today because it's changing very rapidly in
terms of what we know about teaching and learning,
what technologies we're using for teaching
and learning, and the policies surrounding
all this, and people's attitudes towards it.
So rather than sort of me... sort of telling
them about this, I wanted the students to
take some ownership over that, and we brought
in Current Events.
And so students... investigate current events,
choose things that are important and meaningful
to them, and bring it into the classroom for
discussion.
And then, over time, we've sort of changed
the way that we do that, so that we think
about the ways that - can we use the online
components more effectively so that students
are doing some of the... thinking about the
issues before they get to class, and then
use the class time for something that's unique?
For the Current Events, we actually think
that there's enough that you can get out of
an article and some questions online and some
online forums so that actually some of that
conversation can happen before they even get
to class.
So, in those cases, there's a current events
article that goes up - usually relatively
short - and some questions that are posed
with it, and students need to read the article
and respond to those questions.
And then what happens in class is a follow-up
to that.
So sometimes there's themes that happened
in student responses.
Sometimes there's an issue raised that was,
that maybe the people who were responsible
for the Current Events that week didn't think
of in advance.
And that's a chance to kind of follow up on
some of that.
And this year actually for the first time
we were actually saw, started seeing some
groups do some interesting activities that
were follow-ups to those as well.
Not just pure discussion, but activities that
sort of brought out some of the big issues,
or sort of pointed out some similar thinking
or dissimilar thinking that was happening
in the class.
There was some that were sort of like voting
with your feet.
So it was a matter of like looking at distributions
on... in terms of viewpoints on issues, where,
you know, people who thought like "Yes" about
one issue and "No" about one issue went to
different sides of the room.
And then there was some debate around the
issues around there.
So it was a nice way to sort of call out,
"OK, there's distributions on issues.
There's people that think different things
about this, but there's reasons for that,
and let's have some dialogue within people
that have common thoughts, and people who
have disparate thoughts as well."